By the end of the 21st century,
humanity is becoming desperate decades of heat waves and droughts have
led to unusually poor harvest while the warming oceans yield fewer fish each
year in the tropical zones,
millions suffer from famines and resource Wars have made millions more flee to
the North. As things quickly get worse in an act of desperation,
the world's governments decide to enact an emergency plan.
It's far from certain that a grim scenario like this will play out,
but the failure of world leaders to effectively address climate change makes it
far from impossible. So in the near future,
it might become necessary to try something radical,
to slow down rapid climate change,
geoengineering interventions.
So massive in scale that they might undo centuries of human behavior
or make everything much worse. What is geoengineering?
Is it really an option? And what have you.
Goes wrong?
Geoengineering methods vary from fantastic ones like constructing giant light
sails in space to seeding clouds with salt or Wilder ones like fertilizing the
oceans with iron to speed up the growth of trillions of algae cells.
In this video,
we'll focus on an intervention we could see during our lifetimes stratospheric,
aerosol injection, a clunky term.
That means that the spring stuff very high up in the atmosphere to keep the sun
away,
keeping the sun away CO2 doesn't heat up the planet on its own.
Almost all of the energy on earth comes from the sun in the fall of
electromagnetic radiation.
About 71% of this energy is absorbed by the earth surface and atmosphere.
This absorbed energy is emitted again,
as infrared radiation and CO2 is able to trap this infrared
radiation and keep it in the atmosphere for awhile.
You can compare this effect with snuggling under a blanket in the morning,
even in a really cold room,
your body emits infrared radiation and the air between your body and the
blankets trap says and creates a warm and comfy feeling.
So one way to call down the panic would be to prevent energy from getting
trapped under our planet blanket,
which is already happening naturally about 29% of the solar radiation
hitting earth is reflected back to space by bright surfaces, like ice deserts,
snow or clouds, more reflection, less energy,
less warming.
We can look at nature for inspiration specifically the 1991 Mount
Pinatubo eruption. The second largest volcanic eruption of the 20th century,
aside from massive devastation and almost 900 dead scientists noted its
strong impact on the global climate.
The explosion objected millions of tons of particles and gas as high as the
stratosphere, which hung around there for a while.
The that's interesting for geoengineering is Salford ArcSight,
a nasty smelling and invisible gas high in the atmosphere.
It produced a haze of sulfuric acid droplets that mix with water and created
giant veils. These veils reduced the sunlight reaching earth surface.
By roughly 1% global.
Average temperatures dropped by 0.5 degrees Celsius.
It took three years until this cooling effect had stopped.
Humans could imitate this process by injecting self articles directly into the
stratosphere. According to some scientists,
this might be surprisingly easy to do,
and we don't even need a lot of new technology for it. According to one study,
it also might be pretty cheap compared with the costs of rapid climate change.
A small fleet of specialized aircraft could ascend once a year and distribute
aerosols along the equator from where they would be spread around the world.
Projections assumed that injecting between five and eight megatons of material
per year would reflect enough sunlight to slow down or even stop global warming.
Giving us precious time to transition the way from.
Fossil fuels. Unfortunately.
There might be a few unhappy side-effects there are a number of potential
issues with aerosol injections. Rainfall patterns could change,
which could negatively affect agriculture and cause famine billions of people
could be affected in the worst case.
Also after the 1991 Mount Pinatubo eruption,
the acid water veils not only cooled down the surface,
they also heated up the stratosphere as it turns out as it is bad for the
ozone layer and the ozone hole over Antarctica was the largest it has ever been
injecting. Sulfur particles over decades could have a similar effect.
The scientists have already suggested using a combination of different minerals
that might have much less harmful effects on the ozone layer,
but more research and experiments need to be done to make sure this could work,
but even if we don't damage the ozone layer, there are other risks.
Politicians and industry might use the cooling effect as an excuse to delay the
switch to a carbon neutral economy.
Even if geo engineering slows down global warming,
humanity is still adding extra CO2 to the atmosphere.
More CO2 in the air means that the oceans absorb more CO2,
which makes them more acidic.
This is already beginning to be deadly to huge ecosystems like coral reefs.
And the longer this continues, the more severe the effects will be.
But it gets worse. Once.
We start pumping particles into the atmosphere on a massive scale,
we might be forced to do so for a long time,
or we could risk eight termination shock.
What that means is that if humanity continues to enrich the atmosphere with CO2,
but at the same time prevents the planet from heating up by blocking solar
radiation. We're sitting on a time bomb. Once we stop geoengineering,
the natural cycle will take over again and earth would heat up.
But after a few decades of keeping the planet artificially cold,
while still releasing massive amounts of CO2, it would heat up much,
much quicker.
An increase in temperature that would take 50 years today could happen in just
10 years.
Such a temperature shock in such a short time would disrupt every major system
on earth so much that it would be impossible to adapt in time.
The worst case scenario could be dramatic famines and the rapid destruction of
ecosystems humanity might survive,
but the survivors would inhabit an unfamiliar and hostile world.
The best case scenario is that once the world has finally fully understood the
existential danger of rapid climate change,
geoengineering can bias a crucial decade or two time to transition era economies
and maybe even pull CO2 out of the atmosphere.
Maybe with technologies that we'll discuss in a future video conclusion,
geoengineering is a scary concept. It's not a solution to climate change,
and it might even be a welcome excuse for the fossil fuel industry to delay the
end of the fossil fuel age over the last few decades,
geoengineering has been so controversial that it stopped many scientists from
doing the experiments necessary to understand it better.
But blankly opposing geoengineering is short-sighted.
The sad truth is we are already running a geo engineering experiment where
testing how fast the world changes. If we add about 40 billion,
tons of CO2 each year,
this experiment is about to get really exciting.
Hopefully we'll never have to use geoengineering,
but if we need to in the future, we better have done the science.
We better be prepared or a panicking humanity might
accidentally press the self-destruct button.
You probably won't have to do any of that yourself,
but who knows better brush up on your science knowledge just in case and our
friends at brilliant can help you with that.
Brilliant is a problem solving website and the app that makes science accessible
in a practical way more than 60 interactive courses,
give you the tools to crack problems and maths, logic,
and engineering all by yourself. Instead of a classic lecture format,
brilliant uses storytelling code writing and hands-on problems to keep you
entertained and engaged this way.
A small daily challenge can build up to real long-term understanding of science
and achieving your STEM goals in a nutshell, brilliant surprises,
you and keeps you on your toes all while sneaking some knowledge into your head
without you really noticing right up our alley,
ready to get a fresh perspective on science,
go to brilliant.org/nutshell and sign up for free.
And there's an extra perk for coats cause art viewers,
the first 200 people to use the link, get 20% off that annual membership,
which lets you view all the daily problems in the archives and unlock every
course. Brilliant helps you end your day, a little smarter,
still the best preparation for the future. We can think of.
[Inaudible].